this episode is brought to you by
curiositystream and nebula where you can
watch the first episode of our brand new
series becoming human stay tuned to the
end of the video for a sneak preview
for hundreds of millions of years life
on Earth was bound by its medium
sea sponges worms and Jellyfish locked
inside their watery domain
life above the surface would have been
inconceivable and impossible for all of
Earth's early creatures
that is until 440 million years ago when
the first creatures stepped on to land
soon life on terrestrial Earth exploded
with all manner of plants and animals
colonizing the globe
but even with all this expansion for a
long time Earth still had a final
frontier a place where no creature had
ever gone the sky
it's a place that seems so improbable
for life to ever exist how can small and
random genetic mutations allow an animal
to go from completely land-based to
Soaring in the skies
and yet if you look out your window
today you'll see many different
creatures that have taken to the skies
to avoid Predators or exploit new
sources of prey and the more closely you
look at Birds bats and bugs the less
similar their flight might seem
compare the wings of a dragonfly versus
those of a macaw and those of a flying
fox
the differences are immediately obvious
one has scaled Wings on its back another
has feathers and the third has webbing
stretched between thin bony fingers
even more mind-boggling is the fact that
the ancient ancestors of all three
organisms were wingless
and given how Divergent they are on the
evolutionary tree we can see that Wings
evolved separately three times what's
more this particular adaptation even
happened a fourth time in the now
extinct pterosaurs
the story of these different
evolutionary paths has fascinated and
befuddled scientists for decades
how do such different organisms go from
land to Sky
it's a question whose answers are still
unfolding and it all starts nearly 400
million years ago in the devonian period
the early fossil records of insects is
extremely scarce and hotly debated
among the oldest known of such fossils
is rhinyonatha hursty first discovered
in Scotland and dating back to around
400 million years
it's a very fragmented fossil in which
only parts of the head are preserved
well enough to study
scientists continue to argue over how to
classify it
some suggest it's one of the earliest
insects to appear others think it should
be classified as a millipede and not an
insect at all
unfortunately the earliest fossil record
for insects is sparse and murky in this
way there are far more ancestors of
arachnids and myriapods in the early
record than there are insects
but this all changed 325 million years
ago when the number of insects seemed to
explode
why because suddenly they were flying
the oldest of these flyers looks a bit
like an ancient dragonfly
the real mystery is how insects manage
to develop those wings in the first
place
unlike the other flying creatures that
we're familiar with today insect Wings
didn't evolve from existing arms and
it's exceedingly unlikely for organisms
to suddenly evolve a whole new body
structure did the wings instead come
from a pre-existing body structure and
if so which ones
this question has been one of the major
mysteries in biology for decades
over time two main hypotheses emerged
one is the turgle hypothesis referring
to the turgum the top of the insect's
body
this hypothesis suggests Wings
originated on the insect's backs
possibly as membranes for gliding
then there's the plural hypothesis
suggesting Wings evolved from the side
body and began as limbs that folded
along the Torso and gradually migrated
up to the back
the Science World has been fiercely
divided over which of these could be
correct for years
but recently we may have gotten closer
to An Answer not by looking at insects
but by looking at Crustaceans and
arthropods
researchers wanted to determine how the
seven leg segments of some Crustaceans
matched up with an insect's six segments
to figure out which segments were
homologous to which
in evolution homology refers to similar
body parts in different animals due to a
shared ancestry
sometimes this is obvious a human's left
arm is remarkably similar to a cat's
left forelimb or even a whale's left fin
for example
but when comparing insects Crustaceans
and arthropods it's not as clear which
leg segments correspond to which
using a crisper technique the
researchers found that insects and
Crustaceans legs are homologous if you
simply counted the segments from the leg
tips in towards the body
but what about the crustacean's seventh
leg segment or the eighth leg segment of
an arthropod
what part of the insect does that
correspond to
using genetic Knockouts and gene
expression Imaging the researchers
realized that the seventh leg segment of
crustaceans was in fact homologous to
insect pleura its side body while the
eighth leg segment of arthropods was
homologous to the insect's turgum its
top
and on top of this they identified Wing
genes inside of part of the insect's
turgle plate strongly suggesting that
insect Wings evolved as outgrowths of
the turgum
so millions of years ago the eighth leg
segment for some became wings
and while this debate isn't fully
settled what we do know is that insects
evolved flying only once
it was such a useful adaptation that
they've become among the most successful
of all animals
they live on every continent and have a
stunning array of behaviors and niches
to fill
perhaps then it's no surprise that once
insects an important food source were up
in the air the ability for flight began
to evolve elsewhere in the animal
kingdom the next animals to fly were the
biggest flying creatures to ever exist
creatures that dominated the skies for
millions of years
[Music]
pterosaurs were flying reptiles that
could be anywhere from the size of a
pigeon to the size of a Cessna Aircraft
they lived between 225 and 66 million
years ago successfully cruising the
skies for around 160 million years which
is much longer than modern birds have
been around while some were
astonishingly large most early
pterosaurs were pretty small and
insectivorous because some species had
clawed fingers it was thought that they
could climb trees and move about
arboreally this led to a few hypotheses
for how pterosaurs got their wings
the first is the arboreal leaping Theory
basically that the earliest ancestors of
pterosaurs hopped around tree branches
evolving first to Glide then to fly
similar to that was the arboreal
parachute model it was essentially the
same idea but instead of using extra
skin to Glide these creatures would have
relied on their arm flaps to catch
themselves if they fell out of the trees
or jumped to avoid predators
lastly there's the ground up Theory
this hypothesis suggests that pterosaur
ancestors were terrestrial and in their
hunting they might have run and jumped
to catch prey eventually this led them
to develop wings
and this last Theory seems like it might
be the most likely according to a recent
study
scientists recently discovered
fossilized tracts from early pterosaurs
which showed them to be agile
quadrupedal walkers but because
pterosaurs had partly hollow bones to
assist in their flying ability they
didn't fossilize nearly as frequently as
dinosaurs so we're left still trying to
find answers
the fossils we do have show an
incredible range of diversity especially
for the second half of their existence
around that time about 125 million years
ago they became even more diverse
doubling in the number of species
possibly because of the arrival of more
flying creatures ancient Birds
[Music]
the oldest fossil ancestor of modern
Birds is archeopteryx dating back 150
million years ago
it was discovered in Germany only two
years after Darwin published the Origin
of Species and the strangeness of its
body contributed a lot to the debate
about evolution
archeopteryx had an odd mixture of Avian
and reptilian features
feathers and wings allowed it to fly but
it also had teeth and a long bony tail
and modeling by scientists suggests that
the wing movement was very different
from the way we see modern birds fly
it would have moved like a swimmer doing
the butterfly strip with the arms coming
forward then back instead of the up and
down motion of birds flapping their
wings today
archeopteryx wasn't the first dinosaur
to have feathers earlier species did as
well even if they didn't have all the
adaptations needed for flight
that suggests that feathers might have
been an adaptation related instead to
sexual selection
the bright colors could have been a way
for the dinosaurs to display themselves
to potential mates just like with many
modern Birds
so if feathers weren't the thing that
led to flight what did
like with the pterosaurs the main
hypothesis for Avian flight include
trees down and ground up
one test with winged robots showed that
their movement benefited much more when
they were gliding than when they were
flapping their wings while running which
suggests that the benefits of gliding
between trees spurred Birds to develop
flight
another piece of evidence for the tree's
down hypothesis was the discovery of
microraptor a little dinosaur with four
wings that lived about 120 million years
ago
as researchers studied the anatomy of
microraptor they realized its long
feathers on its feet would be a
hindrance during running
it unlikely that it could run fast
enough for the ground up theory of
flight they concluded it was probably
capable not only of gliding between
trees but also full flight
ultimately pterosaurs and dinosaurs went
extinct after the meteor crashed into
Earth 66 million years ago
but birds continued to exploit the skies
in the aftermath and their bodies show
just how well adapted they are to flight
like pterosaurs birds have hollow bones
to reduce body weight
they also have unidirectional
respiratory systems which means air
moves mainly in One Direction instead of
moving in and out the way breathing
works with humans
essentially what happens is that when
birds breathe in the oxygen fills sacs
around their lungs
when they breathe out the air from those
sacs is pushed into the lungs this way
their lungs are never empty and lacking
oxygen
this adaptation helps birds get much
more oxygen and helps to power their
flight
but after the meteor Extinction event
that killed off the dinosaurs birds
weren't the only ones who scrambled to
fill the aerial Niche they were soon
joined by an unsuspecting little mammal
the oldest known bat fossil dates back
to 52.5 million years ago
it's known as the quad bat because it
had claws on all five fingers unlike
modern bats which have two claws per
Wing at most researchers suggest that
having more claws meant this ancient bat
climbed around trees and might have even
been a quadruped when it wasn't flying
another big question with bats is
whether they evolved echolocation or
flight first
scientists have argued over whether this
ancient bat had the right Anatomy to
allow for echolocation but there haven't
been any definitive answers
researchers think that the most likely
evolutionary pathway that led to bats
being able to fly was that they started
out as gliders
the question is what led them to Glide
between the trees in the first place
were they hopping from limb to limb to
get fruit or were they chasing down
flying insects and if they were chasing
insects does that mean they needed to
develop echolocation before flight so
that they could locate their prey
these questions are all still being
explored and debated what we know for
certain is that bats developed very
unique flight characteristics compared
to birds
the Batwing called a potagium is formed
by skin membranes stretched between the
fingers and attached near the ankle it's
much more flexible than a bird wing
which allows bats a higher degree of
fine motor control
bats have as many as 25 actively
controlled joints in their forelimbs so
they can twist their wings into many
shapes making them extremely agile
Flyers
but another difference from Birds is
that they have a title by phasic airflow
system this is the same type of
breathing that we do a breath in fills
the lungs with oxygen but when we
breathe out the lungs are empty and just
waiting for more oxygen
this is much less efficient than Birds
unidirectional airflow system
not only does it mean bats can't fly as
high as Birds where there's less oxygen
it might also be the reason why there
are some very large flying birds but no
enormous bats
the largest bat today is the Flying Fox
a Genus that includes about 65 species
of bat their wingspan can get as large
as five feet which sounds pretty big but
compare that to the wandering Albatross
which has the largest wingspan of the
avian family at 11 feet
bats just don't seem to have the right
Anatomy to ever grow so large
but that doesn't mean they haven't been
successful
thanks to their wings over 1400 species
of bat exist today
they account for almost a quarter of all
mammal species and they're found on
every continent except Antarctica
clearly life on the wing is pretty good
while bats Birds bugs and the extinct
pterosaurs might have found their way to
flight through different evolutionary
pathways
they each discovered an entire new world
of possibilities in the sky
Evolution teaches us that every possible
Niche on Earth can and will get filled
no matter how unlikely it seems and
surprisingly the journey to flight in
all these animals mirrors our own
evolutionary Journey
just as flight unlocked a new Niche for
so many creatures so too did bipedal
movement for our species
no longer bound by the inefficiencies of
quadrupedal movement early upright
humans soon dominated the planet
but how did our early ancestors evolve
such a unique and honestly strange way
of locomotion and what about bipedal
movement made our species so
unbelievably successful
questions like these have swirled in my
head for the last few years
on this channel I talk extensively about
the evolution of other animals but what
about our own Evolution these questions
are what led to the creation of our new
series becoming human
here's a sneak preview
when we look at our closest living
relatives we are reminded of our
particular place on The evolutionary
tree
it's hard to gaze into the eyes of any
of the great apes and not see a
reflection of ourselves The Chimps
gorillas bonobos and orangutans all
resemble us in many ways in both body
and behavior
but how exactly did we diverge so
drastically from the other primates
is it just our big brains that make us
so different or something more what were
the defining steps in the history of our
Evolution that made us the walking
talking thinking feeling Society
building Apes that we are
what were the moments that made us human
I wanted to do a deep dive on the
subject and break the mold of what our
videos normally are
I wanted to take our time with it and
not worry about what the YouTube
algorithm thinks I wanted to focus on
the quality the art and the
multi-episode story things that YouTube
doesn't always reward you for and for
these reasons becoming human is our
first nebula original series nebula is
the perfect place for us to experiment
with new experimental content like this
it's our playground for new ideas and
right now you can watch the first
episode of becoming human over on nebula
nebula is the streaming platform made by
me and several other content creators as
a place for our videos to live at free
and without the YouTube algorithm
dictating what we should or shouldn't
make it's a place full of exclusive
original content from dozens of
different creators and signing up is the
single best way to support this Channel
and luckily right now we are offering an
incredible deal nebula has partnered
with curiositystream so you get both
services for just 14.79 for the entire
year that's 26 percent off the usual
price with two great streaming services
for the price of one
so go to curiositystream.com real
science to get in on this incredible
deal and watch our brand new series
and if you're looking for something else
to watch right now you can watch our
previous video about the world's biggest
stinkiest and weirdest flower or watch
real engineering's latest video about
the insane engineering of the Spitfire